[Music]
hello
voters non-voters dead voters
people who voted twice and everyone else
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for november 12
2020 and you may notice that i'm in a
slightly different situation than usual
i am live right now at the blaze tv
studios here in dallas
texas i actually traveled folks for the
first time
since february last february i was in
florida i came home from florida and
then i didn't realize i wasn't going to
travel
for the next nine months considering i
usually do three or four
speaking gigs or college gigs or
whatever it might be a month
then of course lockdown happened and i
have been in los angeles
every day since around february 21st
and last night i got on an airplane
and i flew to dallas texas and here i am
i made it i'm alive i'm okay
i even checked into a hotel it's
incredible stuff you can actually still
travel despite everything going on
uh so yeah i'm thrilled to be here with
the blaze people they've got a great
team
and we're going to do our show as normal
i've got three stories for you obviously
there's
a ton going on uh in the world right now
and with the election and everything
else
but just real quick i wanted to talk
about just just traveling again and
everything else because i went to
lax los angeles international airport
yesterday and after not traveling for so
long
being in a pretty much empty airport i
don't know how many of you guys have
traveled
since this whole whole thing started but
to be in an empty airport where all of
the
the restaurants were closed actually the
bookstore was open
at the american airlines terminal and i
saw don't burn this book in a bookstore
for the first time believe it or not
the book came out in april and i have
not been to a bookstore even i've seen
it in target
a couple of times but i actually got to
see my book in a bookstore which was
pretty great it was right next to
ben shapiro's book you know that shapiro
guy um
but just seeing all of these people you
know everyone's in masks everyone's
standing away for themselves
everyone i mean i don't know if i was
noticing this more than usual or it's
happening more than usual or what
but everybody just staring at their
phone right like
there's because you're not talking to
anybody so it's eerily silent it felt
very dystopian uh but in any event got
on the plane it turned out that i was
sitting next to a pilot who was just uh
doing some traveling
not actually flying the plane who was a
fan of mine we had a great chat and it's
just
more it's further proof that there are
people out there that are that are
waking up to some of this stuff
uh and then i went to a hotel where i
had to wear a mask in the lobby but then
when i
sat down at the restroom i could take
the mask off and then when i got
up from the table then i had to put the
mask back on i did not wear a mask in my
hotel room
and here we are okay guys so the three
stories that we're going to cover today
first i'm going to cover a couple things
going on election wise
uh on the twitter you know about that
twitter machine
but the secretary of state of arizona
who's going to be in charge of
the recount and everything else going on
there and the results tabulating the
final results
she is not a fan of donald trump and she
has the tweets to prove it and yes
it involves the n-word nazi of course
could i do a story without uh somehow
someone calling trump a nazi i don't
think so so we're
we're going to cover that and then some
tweets by uh joe biden's potential
chief of staff who has in the past
claimed that elections
were rigged and then donald trump just
tweeted something in all caps that we
definitely have to cover so we're gonna
get to that
uh then we're gonna talk about these new
new york curfews i have just had it
with andrew cuomo as you guys know i've
only lived in new york and los angeles
which is a very bizarre thing because
everyone that likes me lives in the
middle of the country i should clearly
be living in idaho or something
um but there are new regulations uh in
new york for bars restaurants gyms and
all sorts of other stuff so we're gonna
get into that and uh and then finally
the story is
a little bit of an offshoot of what's
going on but i think you'll see why i
want to cover it
university of haverford or haverford
college in pennsylvania
a bunch of students basically have
accomplished a list of demands that they
want the university to adhere to
and it involves all that faux diversity
stuff and fake tolerance
and the rest of it that we talk about
all the time and i thought that would be
a little a little break from just the
pure political stuff but it does seem
that woke-ism ain't leaving the colleges
as
easily as it might but before i get to
all of that guys i want to talk to you
about glint okay guys i've got my glint
card right here i know this is a mock-up
card
so you can't look at my numbers and take
my glint money but glint is really it's
a really
fantastic system that you can buy and
sell
gold you can then use your card to make
purchases virtually anywhere i showed
you guys yesterday i
bought a brand new basketball on
amazon.com through this this morning
i went on nike.com and i bought myself
some new sneakers so we'll debut those
new sneakers in about a week
my new kicks but you can pay in gold or
in cash you can transfer back and forth
super easily and we i don't have to tell
you we live in some crazy times guys so
if you're
if you're a little nervous about what's
gonna happen to the dollar then
obviously
uh gold is a great way of having a
little bit of
financial security so check it out it's
just super easy you get the card and it
operates basically like your debit card
and within the app you just
you just choose am i going to pay with
gold or am i going to pay
out of my normal bank accounts and you
go from there it's really fantastic so
take a look
you guys can sign up for free at
glintpay.com
reuben and you can get some more
information and start purchasing gold
today that's glintpay.com
reuben and now back to me okay guys
let's
let's talk about the latest with the
election i want to pull up some tweets
by the secretary of state of arizona her
name is katie hobbs
and these are a couple tweets that she
had from 2017.
uh this is katie hopps secretary of
state so remember this is the woman
that will be in charge of what happens
with the election in arizona
and in august of 2017 she said real
donald trump has made it
abundantly clear that he's more
interested in pandering
to his neo-nazi base than being
president of the united states
for all americans and actually just a
few days before that she had this gem
she said the president is on the side of
the freaking
nazis don't just say stuff
do something and she used all caps there
so let's let's unpack this for a little
bit now the cries of nazis and everyone
who disagrees with you is a racist and a
homophobe and a bigot okay we're
i think uh if you've been watching this
show long enough we're all kind of past
the point where any of that has any
validity but
there is some validity to the idea that
the woman
who is in charge now of what will happen
with arizona's election results the
secretary of state
of arizona clearly has some level of
trump derangement syndrome and clearly
thinks trump is a nazi
now do you think that might just
you know i know everyone's a conspiracy
theorist these days but do you think
that that
might affect her ability to be impartial
when it comes to recounts
or tabulating results correctly or
whatever it might be i think it might
it it just might right does that does
that make me tin foil hat alex jones the
frogs are turning everybody gay
i'm not sure but i think there's
something there this is the type of
thing by the way
that the mainstream media refuses to
talk about right so it leaves
the youtubers and the folks here at the
blaze and the daily wire and all these
other places and me and crowder and
everybody else
to talk about these things because it
that what i just showed you there her
comments in and of themselves
they're obviously not evidence of fraud
just like that right they're not
evidence that she necessarily is going
to do something
but it is something that colors the
picture and you know
i mean this is this is the part and this
is what's so dangerous about what the
left has done
over these last couple years by calling
everybody nazis and and bigots
if if she's looking at these numbers at
the end and it's like whoa
these things are pretty close but trump
trump did win do you think it would be
out of character
or even a crazy estimation to think that
she might
do something to stop the man that is
leading the nazis like do you think that
that's crazy
but this is what we've been reduced to
and by the way it's not just her the
the uh attorney general of pennsylvania
shapiro i've mentioned him a few times
no relation to ben shapiro as far as i
know
he tweeted out about four days before
the election that trump will lose
well how did he know trump was gonna
lose four days before the election and
now we've got some weird stuff going on
in pennsylvania in philadelphia
specifically so if you have partisan
people that are in charge
of the apparatus of these states you got
a problem on your hand and that that's
one of the things that we're going to
have to keep
discussing over the next couple weeks
because the mainstream media just they
just won't touch it
as i always say if you guys would just
do your job i'll find something else to
do
i wanted to be in the nba okay i'd like
to make that dream a reality as i said i
just got a basketball
and and i'm getting new kicks with my
glint card so come on people help me out
you know what i mean let me do something
else for a living but i want to show you
uh two other tweets that are important
so one of them
uh is a tweet from a couple years ago
this is from actually
july of 2014 and this
is ronald klein and ronald klein we can
throw that tweet up there
uh he is responding to an article in vox
and the article in vox as you can see it
says
that 68 percent of americans think that
elections are rigged now just very
quickly on vox you guys know i do not
like vox
i find them to be awful as recline who
uh
runs vox i don't think is an honest
actor he's he's written uh some
pieces about me um and the type of
things that that i do here and what the
things that i'm talking about and all
that stuff
well there's the article 68 of americans
think elections are rigged now it
doesn't even matter whether that's true
or not or whether vox is doing actual
research there
the the contents of the article actually
are completely irrelevant you see the
headline there and we live in an odd
time
where the headline sort of means more
than the story well well
ronald klein again he is potentially the
chief of staff
so basically running the white house for
joe biden well let's look at his
response
his response that's because they
are all right you got that guys that's
what ronald klein
is saying that that's because they are
meaning 68 of americans think elections
are rigged
his response that's because they are
so the chief of staff of the potentially
incoming
president thinks that the elections are
rigged he might be right but it might
not be for the reason that he thinks nor
the election that he thinks
so these are just things again that that
color what's going on here but
let's go to the most important tweet of
the day i just saw this about an hour
ago this is that that donald trump guy
you guys have heard of him right
and he did it in all caps so you know
it's something uh report
dominion and dominion is the software
company that many of these states used
to run their elections dominion deleted
2.7
million trump votes nationwide data
analysis
finds 221 000 pennsylvania votes
switched from president trump to biden
941 000
trump votes deleted states using
dominion voting systems
switched 435 000 votes from trump
to biden and this is based on reporting
he tags the the journalist there that
was on oann now
okay first off he's using caps
so you know trump really means it when
he's using caps um
i cannot comment on the veracity of that
claim i cannot sit here and tell you
that that is true
what i can tell you is that this would
be a very
very curious move by trump if it was not
true so let's
let's play it out here so the not true
version is that's not true it's
fabricated and he just went
all in he just went all in on the lies
all caps he picked specific numbers he
talked about the
voting software and the whole thing and
he's going all in
to get all of his people crazy that
would be the dishonest version of this
now that seems very hard for me to
believe right that he would do something
so specific it's one thing to say
oh the election was rigged or you know
we're trying to find votes here or the
attorney general of this state is an
anti-trumper
those are all sort of more vague
generalities that i think you can you
can
talk about in a way that doesn't like
really pin you down to a direct lie
if you think what trump is doing is
lying that right there
giving us the numbers telling us the
software saying this amount were deleted
this amount switched from trump to biden
that is a pretty direct statement that
if he does not have evidence for
that could be the nail in the coffin now
i suspect
my suspicion would be that that trump is
not an idiot
and that he is saying that because
they've seen something
because otherwise to go on the record
with that level of sp
specificity is is pretty crazy so i
think there's
something there i don't know what it is
i suppose we will find out
and as i said this this tweet was from
about 20 minutes before we started here
so i'm guessing that the internet's lit
up with all sorts of theories right now
but we clearly need to look into what's
going on with this dominion software
also the name dominion
right doesn't this sound like a sci-fi
movie at this point how did they steal
the election the dominion software who
was
it was dominion uh yeah it sounds like
something all right
let's jump on to uh to story number two
have you heard about this coven thing
uh well on saturday when they when the
media
whatever they are when they called the
election for for biden suddenly we had
two days of like oh coronavirus is gonna
go away and it's
pretty much done and we got this pfizer
vaccine and it's gonna
cure 90 percent of the people it'll work
on 90 we're all good to go
then monday rolled around and trump
started fighting again
trump said i'm not going to accept these
results we're going to go to all these
states we're going to do all this stuff
and then suddenly you could feel it
online the trump people were starting to
fight back
and then what did the system do it
suddenly brought coronavirus back so
over the weekend you've got thousands of
people partying in in new york and dc
all over the place you've probably seen
the video of the partiers i think in
brooklyn where they're passing around
champagne bottles
and just drinking out of champagne
bottles now that somehow that's not a
super spreader
event but you know if a trump guy shows
up in a mask with a flag
he's you know bigot nazi evil you know
uh super spreader guy um
so suddenly we see all these
celebrations
then trump fights back and then suddenly
now they're telling us that coronavirus
is just that covet
is just blowing up all over the place so
andrew cuomo
andrew cuomo who is the governor of new
york this is a man
who caused the deaths of probably 30 000
people by sending
elderly people back in to homes we know
this
don't take my word for it google it you
can actually find it on the google at
least for now
he also then wrote a book somehow yeah
he wrote it i mean he wrote a book
somebody wrote a form
about leadership during uh kovid
uh he was even on howard stern the other
day promoting his book
um well what has he decided to do he's
got a whole new list
of things that you got to do if you live
in new york oddly i left new york to go
to california so i'm not saying i'm the
perfect man but let's get into some of
the stuff that he has ordered here
i'll read you the exact quote from fox
business cuomo ordered bars
restaurants and any other establishments
with
state liquor licenses to end indoor and
outdoor dining by 10 pm beginning on
friday
the governor said that these
restrictions were necessary after
contact after contract tracing data
showed establishments where alcohol is
served gyms
and indoor gatherings at private homes
were contributing to the spread of
coronavirus
okay so there's a lot here these people
told us
two weeks to flatten the curve they told
us that eight months ago then they told
us oh we're going to just shut down for
the summer
then we rolled into the fall now we're
rolling into
thanksgiving and i guarantee you we're
rolling into the new year they love
power and they love controlling your
life i did
i did the story yesterday about these
ridiculous cdc guidelines about
what you can do in your own home for
thanksgiving
i said i was gonna share the spoon
everyone touched the spoon at my
thanksgiving a lot of people picked up
on that
maybe we'll do it i don't know if you
know if you want your own spoon you can
have your own spoon
the point is we are allowing these
people to control our lives in crazy
ways and we don't
we don't even know why and we don't even
know how it is that they have the power
to exercise this nonsense over us so at
10 pm we're going to close liquor
establishments
we're going to close bars and we're
going to close restaurants so what do
they think happens after 10 p.m
why is 10 p.m the lock down now is it
possible that
some level of kovid is being spread at
bars and restaurants
it is possible as i said i went to a
restaurant last night it was basically
empty it was quite depressing although
the food was pretty good
uh but there's nobody there there's
nobody there because everyone is just
freaked out right now so they are
continually
destroying the economy in the name of
saving all of us
and guess what andrew cuomo i don't
think you can save me
i don't think you can save me i don't
think gavin newsom can save me the only
people
who can save each other are us we can
save each other by doing what we think
is right
in our own individual lives you guy
watching this through the youtube
machine
sitting at home i believe you can
probably make the right decisions for
yourself i know i know
i'm crazy what can i tell you um so
first off okay we got this 10 pm cut off
then yes as i said is it possible that
at a restaurant it could spread is it
possible
that as a gym it could spread is it
possible at your own home
it could spread these are all possible
things yes i don't deny that
but does that mean that the government
has the right
not even the right that the government
has the duty
to do these lockdowns and continue to
destroy our lives look at the numbers of
people that
we have seen rises in suicide and in
alcoholism and we've seen
secondary sicknesses like cancer go up
because people aren't getting screenings
they're not going to the doctor enough
to do preventative stuff
we have seen a cascading series of
problems that we won't even know the
effects of for years and years
but i would say all of this sort of goes
back to what i told you at the beginning
about me traveling they are doing
something to change how we all behave
going to an airport and not being able
to sit at a restaurant
and nobody looking at anybody and i
don't even think they were playing music
if i'm not mistaken and it was
eerily silent nobody looks you don't
make eye contact with anyone
we are doing something that is
anti-human to to separate ourselves and
that is not
to diminish what the reality of the
numbers is but if you think that this
government
that can't really do much of anything
well
right like what does the government
really do well what problem would you
have
that you would go i think the government
should solve it
this is something that actually aligns
lefties and righties right like people
on the right don't want the government
to solve all of their problems that's
very obvious right
so that's one of the things that that's
like a core piece of being on the right
you don't want the government
to solve things the flaw of leftist
thinking is that the government
what they'll tell you i mean this listen
to what any of the progressives say
listen to what the democrats are saying
the government is evil it's patriarchal
it's
uh it's racist it's systemically racist
the rest of it
and what is their answer their answer is
always give it more power
how about we have federal lockdowns i
mean there are literally lefties who
who over the last six months were
telling you trump is hitler and we
needed federal lockdowns
because we needed to give hitler more
power to control all of our lives
you see why this doesn't work most of us
realize the government
ain't working quite right why give it
more power
over your decision-making i think you
should be able to celebrate thanksgiving
as you see
fit and more importantly i think if you
are a restaurant owner or anyone that
owns any sort of shop that you have put
your blood
sweat and tears and life into that
you have the right to to open that
business and do what you think is right
and if you want people to take their
temperature when they come in and wear
masks then that's up to you
and if they don't want to behave the way
you want them to then keep them out but
the idea that we're outsourcing
all of the all of the decision making to
the government and that biden is
literally saying we will have a federal
mass mandate as if
what is happening in downtown new york
city is applicable to what is happening
in rural idaho this is
absolutely crazy and we're running out
of time to wake up to it
all right i want to do one other story
real quick we're tight on time here
uh but uh haverford college uh the
students rose up
against oppressive haverford college uh
and started to negotiate some things
that they wanted
to happen at haverford college you've
probably never heard of haverford
college it's not that
important other than i think what you'll
see here the things that i'm going to
bring up
are indicative of what's happening
across the universities all over the
place
but a bunch of students created a group
it was originally on instagram and this
was in protest
of the shooting of walter wallace jr by
philadelphia police
so this is reported by the by college
news and i'm going to read some of the
demands
that they have extracted out of
haverford college which again you
probably haven't heard of
but i think this shows you what's
happening across colleges all over the
place
they secured 75 000 towards renovation
at the black cultural center okay that
doesn't sound so bad maybe
they need some money to fix some things
there that's just fine they canceled
classes and jobs on election day and
secured holiday pay
for essential employees i actually don't
have a major problem with that i think
you know making sure people can vote is
very important although we do live in a
time where people are
voting uh via mail and i thought that
was supposed to be good so it sort of
seems like you wouldn't need to do that
but okay
uh they guaranteed full funding for all
students who wish to visit a therapist
of their choosing off campus well that
that seems a little strange to me i mean
we're going to fund
students visiting therapists whoever
they want to visit
off campus we can't do that on campus
and why are we funding it and what does
that have to do with going to college
and learning to become an adult
uh they secured a pass fail model for
the fall 2020 semester
no more grades guys that's just
fantastic you either passed or you
failed it doesn't matter if you ace the
test or you you pass by one question you
are the same
which is very much in line with a lot of
what's coming out of the left you
remember kamala harris's
little cartoon right before uh right
before the election where
she was basically promoting communism
and said we will all end up
in the same place that's the beauty of
the system of equity that they want to
create well they're doing that now
at haverford college because you'll
either pass or fail it won't matter
whether you passed by one question or
you or you aced the test
couple others i'll throw two out here
they secured
an annual operating budget of 25 grand
for work completed under the chief
diversity officer now as you guys know
the chief diversity offer
officer usually their job is to inject
systemic racism into the system because
that's what they're doing
under the name of diversity they secured
75 grand for bias training at the
college over the next two years
they guaranteed compensation for up to
20 hours of missed work while
participating in a strike
so if you don't go to work because you
want to strike they'll pay you for it do
you see
how insane this is what does that have
to do with anything what does that have
to do with being an adult
these are the places where we're we're
learning things and there's just one or
two more here that i'll
throw to real quick they encouraged
inter-departmental discussion and
reforms to center anti-racist work in
every discipline
i had no idea that haverford college was
so racist but all of these colleges that
are lefty colleges apparently
they're all very deeply racist and it
goes across curriculums which is
actually pretty amazing and finally they
secured reserve
caps hours for lgbtq students and the
commitment
to hire other another counselors
specializing
in working with lgbtq people you guys
might remember
the famous supreme court case brown
versus the board of ed which decided
that separate
but equal that's no good you can't have
black people in this school and white
people in this school separate equal no
good but apparently now we want to
separate
everybody by race and by gender and by
sexuality
and all of those silly things anyway
it's not that haverford university is
that important but these
things that we've been talking about
about critical race theory
about title ix all of these bad ideas
about
anti-racism which is actually racism and
the way they're injecting it into the
system
it's all still here guys it's all still
here and we got work to do
speaking of work to do i am doing
roughly a bajillion blaze shows while
i'm in town i'm in town for a couple
days
i shot ali stucky's podcast this morning
it was actually a great interview i
think you're really going to dig it so
i'll make sure that i tweet that out
i'm doing some stuff with glenn beck
tomorrow and a couple of the other blaze
hosts i may even see that steven crowder
guy
that that's the rumor we'll see about
that um
and i've got a couple other business
meetings good things are happening
stay sane everybody it's going to be
okay
i promise you and i'll be back tomorrow
thanks everybody